hello everyone can you hear me very good
right there welcome to reinventing the
transaction script probably the most
boring title I've ever done as a tour
title it's after lunch and you know it
sounds like a really boring talk I hope
the talk is not as boring as their title
sounds mmm
so I'm Scott volution I have a web shop
website f-sharp 400 prophets which is um
about F sharp and about fun and profit
so I do a lot of functional programming
and that's part of the theme of this
talk and just gonna what triggered me to
do this talk in the first place is when
I started people seeing people say that
transaction scripts are a bad thing
now if you don't know what a transaction
script is I'm gonna explain in a minute
but for people who were like who came of
age you know 10-15 years ago this is one
of those standard things one of the
standard patents we had and I see people
say you know it's not good enough for
this is anemic
it's an anti-pattern it's more of an
anti-pattern with no sequel that citrus
there's all these things that people say
about them I think people have a
misunderstanding of what they're good
for so I think they are not a bad thing
in fact they are an excellent thing and
I hope to persuade you that they really
are a very good way of thinking about
solving problems so what is a
transaction script this term was created
or popularized by Martin Fowler in his
book patterns of enterprise application
architecture peña a it's normally called
and it came out in 2002 and this was
people who were programming back then
like old people like me this is one of
our Bibles and we you know we
religiously followed all the patterns in
this book and one of the questions he
asked in that book is how do you
organize your domain logic where you
know should you put it here should you
spit it around should how should you do
it and so one of the patterns for this
was a transaction script and the idea is
that most business applications you can
think of as a series of transactions and
so a transaction script is basically all
that all the logic you need
duis transaction is in one single
procedure and he uses the word
procedures of this Holdings and then if
you need to do database stuff you know
you just like literally put the sequel
statements in line or you have a very
thin wrapper or something but basically
everything you need in one place and
each transaction each business
transaction has its own transaction
script so that's pretty straightforward
that's pretty easy and he had some other
patterns in there too I mean here the
transaction script and he had the table
module pan which is really not so
trending right now the domain model
which is now very popular obviously
domain driven design and so on and the
idea of that is you have an object model
and for all the different bits of domain
logic you have a class that specializes
in that particular piece of domain large
you have a customer class and a product
class and a whatever class you know and
the behavior and data are kept together
of your origin and then you also have
services he also mentioned service
layered architecture in this book with
services and application services and
domain services and all that other stuff
so these are the patterns though in the
book and since the main logic is a
really important part of your code you
know people paid a lot of attention to
these pens and of course people have
very strong opinions about these
patterns and the transaction script was
considered like two simples to anemic
table modules to database centric but
you know domain model and services and
layers are good because they're complex
nice and complex complex is good right
and it's just interesting to me that
simplicity is considered sort of a bad
thing and I just want to have a little
side now here about developers and the
way they think about things I mean if
you have a scale from simple to complex
we really do think of simple things as
boring and and complex things as awesome
and interesting and all I have to say no
it's microservices and manetti's and
event sourcing and you can think of all
the things which are complex now it
doesn't mean they're a bad thing
sometimes you need the complexity but we
jump on to the complexity we think
complexity equals good and simple and
boring equals bad and you know Visual
Basic and PHP and stuff are bad because
they're too simple it's like it's too
easy to get stuff done you need to have
a framework
you know so transnational scripts have a
bad reputation you know if you if you
were around in those days and or if you
read the book people think it's
translational scripts are like for
people who are stuck in the 90s and
you're doing a lot of Java or maybe an
evening using COBOL because basically
all COBOL stuff is transaction scripts
right it's just like mainframe stuff so
it's very uncool if you use
transcription a transaction scripts you
an uncool person so I'm going to try and
tell you the revelation that
transactions are actually very cool
because you can use functional
programming if you reinvent them with
functional programming is very cool
because functional program is cool so
function the program based translation
scripts are super hipster and super cool
and then there okay so alright so let's
look at the pros and cons of transaction
scripts a typical transaction
transaction scripts you know get some
data from database doesn't business
logic write some data get some more
business logic maybe there's a little
branch on some condition does some more
database some more business logic etc
etc etc and again this is how most code
used to be written before
object-oriented philosophy came along
but what's interesting about this it's
actually really easy to understand
it's like one thing after another it's
one directional dataflow it's really
easy to understand what's going on so
that's good I mean you know it's all in
one place it's all focused on what's
important right you don't need have a
yangmi reminder because it's nothing
you're not building a framework you're
building something that delivers some
particular piece of value so everything
in this script is relevant to the script
there is no interface that has methods
that you're not using in the scrip
because there were no interfaces right
so it's very very specific is very
relevant that makes it also easy to
understand now on down on the flip side
it's hard to modify if you add new
conditions and you want to try to evolve
this thing you add more conditions and
more conditions and you end up with a
tangled mess of logic sometimes that's
not good and I think it's Martin Fowler
said there's no graceful path to richer
behavior like at some point
throw these away and Creator to me I
know which domain model or often you
just copy and paste the whole scripts
and make your changes and then leave the
original script alone so you don't break
it you know that kind of thing so that's
why they have a bad reputation and
there's no rich domain model we're
literally reading things from a database
doing some logic right in stare at the
database so all the stuff about domain
driven design and having objects with
behavior and stuff that all goes out the
window this is like I say it's very
fifties mainframe style so if I want to
take this piece of code and we use it
for some other script it's really hard
to do because it's not designed to be
modular and it's also really hard to
test because the business logic and the
database logic and we know what makes it
up here's the business logic here's the
database logic they're all tangled
together that makes it really hard to
test trying to write a unit test for
this bit or a unit test for that bit
it's gonna be really hard so you can't
just test individual bits on their own
so those are the problems can we fix
these problems yes we can and that's
what this talk is all about and the
answer of course is to use functional
programming which is cool and domain
during designers call and so we get very
high coolness score by doing this new
reinvented translation script and it's
all about being cool right so let's talk
about functional programming I'm sure
most of you are familiar with functional
programming now but I'm just going to
give you a little intro kind of my way
of thinking about it without the jargon
so here's a function and I like to use
the railway track analogy a lot you'll
see it in all my talks a function is
something or this little bit where we
had a little tunnel a tunnel of
transformation I call it and so
something goes into this tunnel and it
comes out different so an apple goes
into this tunnel and it turns into
banana right so it's an apple to burn on
a function so that's it that's all our
function is it's really simple if you've
played with a like a toy like a Brio
wouldn't where I set this you know you
know how this works but here's a fee
thing about functions is they are
standalone things they are not attached
to a class they're not touch to anything
they are you know all they don't use
global variables if you need extra
parameters you pass in extra parameters
they are completely independent so stand
alone is another word for reusable so
because they're standalone they are much
much more reasonable than things that
aren't standalone and also because
they're standalone you can use them just
like you use a string or an int or a
date or anything they're just values
that you can pass around so if you
sample here is a function which has a
normal input but has another function as
an output or here is a function which
has a function as an input and a normal
thing as nowbut and here is a function
which has a normal thing input and a
normal thing output but you can have
another parameter which is another
function that you pass in which controls
how the main function works and that
controlling another function that's the
strategy pan right there so in
functional programming the strategy
pattern is literally just passing in a
function there's another parameter so
that's it that really is in my in my
world that's everything you need to know
about functional programming seriously
if that's the that's the foundation now
you can get really really complicated
you can have a function that returns
another function there's a factory for
other functions that have parameters you
know I mean it can get really really
complicated but the core principles is
that that is really it and everything
that comes out of that things like
monads and all that stuff it's just the
kind of follow on to this right so the
core functional programming principle
its composition everywhere functional
programmers love to do composition as
their main thing so what is composition
everyone knows what composition is
because hopefully you've all played with
Lego right now Lego has a philosophy
behind it there is actually a lego
philosophy first of all that all the
pieces are designed to be connected and
the pieces are reusable pieces and if
you connect any two LEGO pieces together
you get another kind of piece that you
can keep connecting to like this you
don't have to stop at some point because
you run out of it's to add things on
every Lego bit can be added one too so
here's some Lego and if you notice that
every single Lego piece there's little
bumps on it they're all designed to be
connected that's a key part of Lego if
it didn't have that it wouldn't be Lego
and you know here it's really obvious
you can like build something and you can
take it apart and build something else
so that only works because there are no
strings attached literally there are no
strings attached to LEGO pieces if they
had little wires or something coming out
of them you'll be really much harder to
build things out them and here's the
composition you can connect two pieces
Lego to make a bigger thing connect that
to make a bigger thing to make that to
make a bigger thing and so on and so
forth you do not need a special adapter
you know no point you have to stop and
say I can't continue because I need a
special adapter that I'm you know like
you can always keep going right in just
adding and adding and adding which means
you can start from really small things
and make really big things like that so
this is a very cool piece of Lego this
is a piece of Lego and because of that
you could take two of these and connect
them together to make an even bigger one
right because they still have little
bumps on it that's what I call the power
of composition competition is a great
way to build big things some smaller
things right so the functional
programming idea of composition is the
very same thing so you have two
different functions and you want to
connect them together to make a bigger
function and this is where the railway
analogy is really nice because it's
really obvious if it's bits of railway
how do I connect these two function
together well I literally take the
output of one and plug it into the input
the other and now I have a new function
so that's before and that's after
now what's cool is this new function you
can't tell that was built from smaller
functions I mean from your point of view
this is just a function that turns
apples into cherries and you know where
do the banana go right there the other
function had bananas there are no more
modern honours and this one so the fact
you've got some sort of data hiding
abstraction going on that the Indus
mauler pieces have to worry about the
stuff but the bigger pieces don't but
then this is just another function and I
could connect this to an if there's
another function that consumed cherries
as inputs and spat out pineapples or
something I could take this cherry
emitting function and connect to that
and make an even bigger function right
so the fact that you're using the same
techniques at different scales is really
nice so this composition is you can
build big things from small things
composition all the way up
so here's a little example let's say you
have a low-level operation like
application in a string classic function
you have a string as input the other
strings output you take a bunch of these
low-level operations and you make like a
service like an address validation
service that takes and dresses input and
a validation results as output and
because I'm over 40 I'm going to use the
word service if you're under 40 you can
use the word micro service so you take
all these services or micro services and
you combine them in to make two you know
completely this support a use case or a
story
what if you want to call it by updating
your profile data in the database so you
pass in some data and some stuff comes
out then you take all these use cases
and let's say you're making a web
application a web application is in fact
a function it has an input which is HTTP
request and it has an output which is an
HTTP response so web applications are
functions and so typically inside this
big function there's a some sort of
branch a controller or a dispatcher or
router where you look on it basically
based on what the input is you call one
of the other functions inside and that's
it
so that's functional composition from
the ground up all the way to a big way
about so it's kind of fractal sort of
similar it's a bits it's not quite
fractal it sounds cool to call it
fractals so I'll call it that so here is
like here's like the internals of a web
app now obviously there's branching
going on there is you know lots of
little functions going on but the big
picture is still an input and an output
and you know you literally can't build
bigger things or small things and if you
ask of you know if you look at the
functional programming web libraries
this is exactly how they do it so I have
a whole talk about the power of
composition also from LDC one other
thing I just want to point out which
I'll be mentioning later on is that the
arrows are all in the same direction the
hours go from left to right there are no
loops there are no cycles that makes it
easy to understand right now in
statically type functional programming
we have things called types
and types are just data and they can be
composed too so let me explain how that
works in in a language like f-sharp or
high school or a Carol we have what's
called algebraic type systems that's a
bit of jargon but if you replace the
word algebraic with composable that
makes a lot more sense and it's actually
exactly what it is so a composable type
system what does that mean it makes you
it means you can build bigger types some
smaller types
that's what composition is just like
Lego so in a composable type system
there are actually typically two ways to
build a new type one is to end them
together whatever that means and the
other way is to all of them together now
I'm going to explain what that means in
a second but something to point out is
the composition of types is only
possible because in functional
programming data and behavior are kept
separate if you have the data and the
behavior in the same thing in an object
in object when to programming it's
really hard to do certain kinds of
composition because when you combine two
objects you know which method should
belong to which objects and so on so it
just becomes tricky but if it's just
data it's quite easy to do so what do I
mean by composing with and well just
like when we use English and we talked
about doing n when I say I want a fruit
salad and it's an apple and a banana and
a cherry there's the ingredients I'm
using the word and right and this is you
might call a record type or a tuple or a
pair or struts you know this is a really
really common thing in in any kind of
programming language so here is the Neph
sharp version of this we're saying a
fruit salad is an apple and a banana and
a cherry because they're all the fields
have acquired right it's got three
fields every single field has to be
filled in okay so that's easy enough now
the other way of composing is with or
and again just like in English we would
say if I want to snack I have an apple
or a banana or a cherry so one of the
three choices not all at the same time
just one of three and an f-sharp we use
the vertical bar like this so we say a
snack is an apple or a banana or a
cherry
you can think of this as like a
glorified enum you can think of it as
like a snack fast with three subclasses
not quite like any of those but that's
the kind of idea behind it it's it's a
quick way of making a choice between
different things so I call these choice
types inertia actually call
discriminated unions you can also call
them some types co-products if you fancy
right so let's look at how you actually
build real stuff with I mean it sounds
very nice in theory but how do you
actually use it in practice so here is a
real-world example of building a payment
system let's say that you take three
forms of payment and let's say cash and
PayPal and credit cards now for cash you
don't need any extra information for
PayPal you need an email address and for
credit cards you need card type and a
card number or an expiration date and
all the other stuff so how would you
implement this so how would you model
this if you're going to write code to
implement this requirement so I think it
depends on whether you're an i/o person
or a functional programmer now if you're
an hour person you would probably
implement it as some sort of abstract
base class or an interface called a
payment method and you'd have all the
other things kind of inherit from that
interface or implement that interface on
here from that base class so have a cash
class I'd have a PayPal class would have
a car class and I think most people
would probably do it this way if you and
a person so let me show you a different
way if you're not on our person let me
show you a completely different way of
doing this so in functional programming
I would probably build it up like this
building up a big thing from a bunch of
small things the composition way so we
start off by defining some primitives
because in domain modeling people really
real people do not use words like
strings and floats they use you know
email dresses and card numbers now they
might be represented by string but
that's not in the domain model you know
those kinds of words should never exist
so he have a thing called an email
address we have a thing called a card
number which are our primitives and then
we say well a card type that's a choice
between a Visa and MasterCard so it's a
vertical bar or
and a credit card information is a car
type and a card number so that's an an
type or a record type so we've got a
choice using or and an a record using
and okay
so let's keep going let's build up
something on top that this build our
payment method um so we said a payment
method is cash or PayPal or credit card
so we say Cash or PayPal or credit card
so it's a choice type and for the
different cases there's different
information to go along with each case
so in the cash case there's no
information needed for the PayPal case
we need an email address and for the
credit card case we need the credit card
information so that's a choice type but
we don't have to stop because we can
keep building and building just note
with a Lego you can keep adding and
adding and adding
alright the composition you can just
keep going so let's keep going let's do
some more stuff let's define a payment
amount and again I'm not going to use
the word decimal or float I'm going to
use payment around that's the word they
use currency is say euros or dollars so
it's a choice and then we can keep going
say a payment is an amount and a
currency and a method so and and and
that's a record type so that's how you
build a big domain for a bunch of small
things so we can keep going and going
but that's basically our you know a way
that you can build a big domain for a
bunch of smaller types so that's the
composition in the time system yeah I
think it's very very cool right so let's
apply some of these functional
programming principles to transaction
scripts so transaction script is a bit
of a mouthful so I'm gonna call them
workflows and said so a workflow is some
business operation that adds value to
the business okay now you can call it a
transaction you can call it a story a
use case lots of different words for
these things but I just going to use the
word workflow because it's kind of a
neutral word so workflows are triggered
something happens in the outside world
that triggers your workflow to happen
and typically the workflow if it needs
to tell somebody else that I did
something it emits some events at the
other end saying hey everybody I just
you know took payment for this order now
you can ship it or whatever so that's
how it communicates with the outside
world and if you these events what
triggers things and what comes out the
other side these
events are actually the glue in a
business like something happens that
triggers some workflow the workflow says
I just finished something will that
trigger something else and then they say
I just finished something that triggered
something else how how are the different
business processes are connect my events
is really really important and if you're
not familiar with it I would check out
event storming there's a process for
determining what the business events are
it's a it's a really excellent kind of
like a hyped up agile way of get
everyone in the same room and
discovering what these things are so how
do we implement these workflows well
we're going to implement as a function a
little bit of railway track right so as
an input and output it Maps really well
to functions and the inputs and the
outputs are going to be modeled by these
composable types so when I say it takes
in a payment method and it spits out a
completed order or something those
things will be modeled by payment types
they're not going to be modeled by intz
and strings we're going to be model
modeling them with these nice composable
types okay so I using our everything
we've learned about functional
programming so far that's good and the
other nice thing about functions is
because they're composable it's really
easy to build a bigger workflow from a
bunch of smaller ones and so you know in
a transaction screen a classic
transaction script it's not at all
modular it's just one thing after
another but when you're doing functional
programming modularity is like built-in
and as I say that functions are
standalone you can't almost can't help
but have a modularity so it's really
easy to build a workflow from a bunch of
smaller pieces and so you have these
individual pieces you glue them together
to make a bigger piece and that's all
your workflow because each of these
components are standalone like I said
they're not attached it's not methods in
a class because they're standalone you
can use them anywhere so you could use
them in different workflows different
anything like but they're very
completely standalone right so let's
talk about the maned of a design for
people who are not familiar with
remainders in design it comes from this
book by Eric Evans that was published
just after PAA 2003 and his key insight
is to focus on the domain
and the domain logic rather the
technology developers love to talk about
technology the business does not care
about technology they just want to
deliver value so focus on that forget
about the technology it's not the most
important thing now a July
had a good start with this because in
agile rather than having the whole
waterful thing you have the domain
experts or the on-site customer or
whatever you want to call them and the
development team talk to each other it'd
be in the same room as much as possible
really interact rather than being
detached you know and then the developer
write some code and the code turns in
deliverable and you get feedback from
the domain expert as frequently as
possible so agile is very good it's all
about fast feedback but there is one
little problem with agile which is that
the code is often still a translation
from the developer's head
so the code tends to be very developer
centric now in domain driven design we
solve this problem by trying to create a
shared mental model that everyone
involved in the product share Smith said
everyone uses a Prada owner's subject
matter experts domain experts on-site
customer whatever want to call them and
in particular this shared language is
used in the code as well okay so here we
have our code it is not a translation
from the developers mental model into no
code it is the same code it's the same
mental model as the domain experts are
using so ideally the domain experts can
look at your code and give you feedback
on it because it's the same you're using
the same words in your code they're used
to using and it becomes sort of
documentation as well so there you go
your shared languages in the code so
this is approach that I think is really
good for doing design we have the
contribution from agile which is you
rapid feedback the domain driven design
site is you have this shared mental
model and you have the code also
represent the shared mental model so if
you do that and when I've done this kind
of thing projects tend to be quite
successful so communicate the design in
the code is a key domain driven
principle now at this point a lot of you
are Polish saying yeah that's nice and
theory but can you actually make the
code
and the domain is that even possible
because this is what source code looks
like we all know this is what's also I
mean even the right even doesn't evoke
this couldn't understand this way so
this is what people think source code
looks like so let me show you what I
think source code should look like now
what you have to do is you have to guess
what domain this is this is f sharp code
by the way you have to guess what domain
it is and what the various concepts are
on what the key well the key concepts
what the shared language is okay well I
think it's pretty obvious it's something
do with cards because it says card game
right at the top these words down the
side the suit and the rank and I think
this is the shared language of the
domain and they're right in front of you
so if I'm a new developer and coming on
to this project and I don't know
anything about cards you know let's say
if I just look at this code I can
already have a good idea of what's
important in the domain I don't have to
go to 20 different files it's like
staring me in the face that's very nice
so what they I mean and I you can
actually get feedback from non
developers I mean I say to the devote to
non develop as I say you know a vertical
bar means a choice and that little star
means a pair and that's means a list and
every time you see the arrow I call
these actions or workflows right so I'm
gonna just go into that a bit so I'm
gonna get on modeling workflows with a
function so to deal to deal some cards
you start off with a deck you have a
deck in your hand
and after you've dealt a card on the
table you now have a card on the table
and you have it that in functional
programming things immutable so you
can't change deck you can't mutate the
deck all you have to do is make a clone
of that deck with that card missing so
you have a new copy of the deck or a
mute a version of their deck without
that card anymore so that's the output
is a new deck and a card on the table so
we can model this in an in a functional
way saying all the input is a deck and
the output is a pair you know you have
your deck and you have the card on the
table and again if you want to pick up a
card from the table the input is the
hand that I have and there's a card on
the table
that's everything I need to do this
function and if I need something else
that would be another parameter and then
after I've picked up the card the card
on the table is missing and it's no
longer there and I have a new version of
my
and again I have to I thought when you
take my hand I have to make a copy of
the hand with this new card added so
that's how you would model picking up a
cardi at the input there's two
parameters in the input and there's one
parameter on the output or one thing on
the output okay so here's our domain do
you think this is a reason about of code
to write to capture domain I think yes
is fits on one page which is really nice
in practice you think well this is a
simple domain but I've worked on really
complicated it means like tax and you
know four or five pages maybe and this
is just like one slight it's amazing the
process of doing this is actually a
great way to get everyone on the same
page in a business even though people
often you have people who are different
teams and they actually don't even
communicate and doing this actually
forces them to get everything on there
getting them on the same page do you
think a non programmer could understand
this so when I was doing the workshop
and I was like typing this up
somebody said some of the product
manager not not a developer said well
this is great this is a really nice
documentation but where's the code and
you know it's not really obviously this
is actually compatible code which is
kind of cool do you think
non-programmers could provide useful
feedback to this so there is actually a
deliberate mistake and you want to see
what the mistake is ace is missing there
you go very good now if you're a non
programmer I think you could still give
that feedback I mean again in my
experience like in is there some kind of
complicated cases they can provide
information you forgot to handle this
particular case because there's no code
there's no implementation here this is
kind of we want to think of it as
designing the interface for the domain
so there's a reason why it's called
domain driven because it's not database
driven right there's no foreign keys
there's no joins there's no you know
tables anything it's all about the
terrain everything here is about the
domain and the domain driven design
people call this persistence ignorant
meaning you you don't know anything
about how this gets stored now obviously
in a real app you do have to store this
somewhere in a database or file or
whatever but that's not part of the main
that logic of how you store something
you know it's important it's part of the
implementation but it's not part of the
domain logic right so it's we're
important to keep them separate
also it's not our driven there no base
classes there are management classes no
factories if you have two different
concepts like a hand and a deck they
might have the same representation as a
list of cards you model them as
something completely different you don't
have a base class
they both inherit from right that's not
the way how the real world works so in
the real world you have these words
these concepts and in the code you have
the same concepts that's the main during
design so the domain has to be in sync
with the real world all right there's no
translation you're not translating what
the what the experts think into your
code you try and use exactly the same
words so that's the right way of doing
and now what you shouldn't do is not use
any kind of programmer jargon let's see
you need something to manage all these
different players so you have a player
controller or player manager and then
you say well the deck and the hand as
soon as let's create a base class and
let's create an abstract card proxy
factory mean or something play these
these words do not belong in the domain
right now they may in the implementation
obviously the implementation can get
tricky but in the domain side of things
the interface side of things they should
not exist okay so if you're doing if you
see those kinds of words in your domain
you're doing it wrong so what I like
about this is the design and the code or
the same thing typically this is the
first file you know like an f-sharp
project and the rest the code has to
conform to this so this is the design
it's sort of the interface for the rest
of the code that has to implement it but
it always stays stays and sync you never
have this problem where a UML diagram is
out of sync or a word document is out of
sync you know the code and the design
and same thing so this is X is
executable code this is not pseudocode
right so communicating the design and
the code is one of the key principles
and I think we did that quite nicely
right so there's one other thing I want
to talk about in domain design there's
lots and lots of jargon unfortunately in
the main design if you read the blue
book sadly there's a lot of jargon and
they really shouldn't be talking because
it's meant to be user friendly but there
is a useful concept called bounded
contexts
and I think it's extremely useful
concept for us to think about when you
when you're implementing something in
your domain model or your code you know
there's naturally kind of areas of
things where the similar functionality
like if you've got an e-commerce site
there's an order taking part there's a
shipping part as a billing part River so
the DVD people call these components a
bounded context and it's really really
important to think about what these
things are and how they are defined the
boundaries are very important that's why
they called bounded context so a context
right means a specialized piece of
knowledge common language within that
area and if you take it out of context
it means something different or it's
unusable and I've seen situations where
often you try and have maybe a
company-wide project to define what a
customer is and the marketing people
have a definition of a customer and the
billing people the finance people have a
definition of customer and they're
incompatible definitions because you
know they may use the same word but
they're different you know marketing
people it's all about sparing you and
billing finance be was all about you
know our new money and stuff features
very different so just because they use
the same word doesn't mean it's the same
thing so the context is really important
and it's where it's just you know be
very aware to try and have a global
context that everything fits into
normally in a business there's
specialized knowledge specialized
context and if you take it out of that
context you end up trouble and the
boundary boundaries are very important
just like with human relations relations
between software components need to have
boundaries otherwise you're in trouble
and one of the reasons for having
boundaries is to make them autonomous
because if you don't have a boundary and
everything's gonna mush together you
always find that if you change something
over here it's gonna break something
over here and if you have a boundary a
wall between them you know you can
freely change this bit and not have to
worry about the other bit changes it's a
bit like if you're running a
three-legged race you know if you're
tied to somebody at the ankle something
it's really hard to run even if you're
the world's best athlete you're still
not going to run very fast if you
separate people something run
independently they do much better
so boundaries keep you focused and they
stop doing stuff you're doing scope
creep really really important so here's
about a context and we're gonna middle
our workflows as little things in our
bounded context so banner context is
really from our modeling point of view
just a set of related workflows things
which belong together
because they have something in common
they use the same vocabulary they use
the same terminology now if you have a
workflow that doesn't belong in the span
of context well and you stick in another
one and it's really easy to do because
there's no dependencies they're
standalone things right because we're
implementing workflows as functions so
they're really easy to move around is
really easy to refactor if you make a
mistake right so we're finally ready to
reinvent the transaction script so we're
going to take two parts the functional
programming part is to implement
transactions as functions and then we're
going to build them from components
using composition so rather than just
having a big mass of stuff in a big file
we can break it down into little pieces
and build a logical composition now
what's interesting about it is if you
break it into let's say you have a
little component in your in your thing
and you only use it in this one
translation script that's fine it's not
a problem but if you ever do want to use
it in another translation script because
the function is a standalone because all
the parameters are passed in because
they have no dependencies on global
State it's really easy to reuse
functions in different contexts now the
functional domain modeling contribution
which I just showed you is using
composable types to create a rich domain
model now we said the beginning that one
of the problems with transaction scripts
is they don't have a rich domain model
it's just a bunch of strings and intz
and database calls so if you do this
nice domain what anything you can
actually get these really nice puzzle
types yet the individual actions are
still standalone if you have an
object-oriented domain idle where you
have a lot of objects and they all talk
to each other it's really hard to pull
out the individual methods because
everything's sort of tangled up but in
this kind of fashion or domain model you
can still have the rich
the main model but the individual
actions because their model has
functions again they are standalone
things and you can refactor them pull
them out put them somewhere else much
more easily and again we're going to
steal this idea of bounded context as a
way of grouping and managing workflows
so everything in a particular plan of
contexts has the has the same kind of
context the same vocabulary right so
let's go and look at the pros and cons
that I talked to her at the very
beginning I said one of the pros about
transaction scripts they're really easy
to understand and they're super focused
because everything in them is relevant
that's good and then I said some of the
cons where they are hard to modify hard
to evolve hard to reuse there wasn't a
rich domain model and they were hard to
test
so all these downside so I think this is
one of the reasons why I translation
scripts have become out of fashion but
let's see if we can solve these problems
so I'm gonna make a number of claims
this is what I personally think of
course just like in unfortunately given
that software is like a trillion dollar
business we have so little hard evidence
for anything is really shocking actually
I'd be quite happy to have like you know
double-blind tests all this stuff but
literally people just make stuff up and
this is a conference that kind of
conference where people do make stuff up
and say that's my way is the best way of
doing something so that's exactly what
I'm going to say I'm gonna say my way is
the best way of doing something so I'm
going to claim that doing this approach
is really good so I'm going to say first
of all that there's a functional style
translation scripts are actually easier
to comprehend than an object model okay
so here's a functional functional
pipeline or transaction script all the
arrows go left to right there are no
backward arrows makes it much I think
that's really really I mean people
really underestimate how important this
is I think makes it really easy to
understand and again if you have it like
a whole web framework or something I
have a whole web app implemented as a
function you can always follow the data
through left to right and I can't and I
can't stress how easy that it makes
debugging so even with the branches sis
yeah there's branches but the branch is
all going the same direction
so that's awesome now in an
object-oriented workflow you have this
kind of request response model not input
output but request response so I took
there's a particular object I send a
request to and I get a response from
them that object will then talk to
somebody else that object will then talk
to somebody else who'll talk to somebody
else or something else and there may be
a little bit of back and forth and
eventually if they go back to the main
object and the main object gives me back
the response that I asked for and it's
easy to accidentally make this very
complex now if you do it right just to
just a you know I mean I'm not hating on
oh well because I actually used to do a
lot of small talk and small talk is
awesome and if you do it right it's very
nice but it's very very easy to make the
overly complex because the arrows go in
all directions trying to chase down
where you're going can be really hard
now what's interesting when we did
micro-services we do not design
microsomes this way if you saw a
microservice that taught another michael
service which then taught to the
original michael service which talked to
third microservice that one could be
sidon bad design all right that would be
really bad and even for Microsoft design
and yet we design our stuff that way so
I would take the same principles and
apply them to our design to try and have
a linear one-directional model now this
is a graph that I built myself by
analyzing the dependencies in a c-sharp
project and there are easily a couple
hundred classes every little line is a
dependency from one class to another
class meaning that class reference that
hull-loss and what you can't see first
of all you can see it's really
complicated and what you can't see is
that the arrows go in all directions and
you actually get slightly dependencies
now cyclic dependencies are evil I have
a whole talk about that they're really
really evil because you they all tie
together you can't pull a piece out
because it depends another piece which
depend on peas literally when you do
that you have no more layering you know
you have no more top to bottom they're
all in one layer everything that depends
another circle you might as well make it
one object because you're not getting
any benefit
so now this is interesting this is this
f-sharp project so this is C sharp and F
sharp so the same dotnet underneath the
F sharp project basically exactly the
same functionality but as you can see
there are a lot less components in it
and what you can't also see is that all
hours are going left to right so even if
you you know if you look the zoom in you
can actually follow the code all the way
through so yes this you know that some
some pieces have big dependencies but
there's a lot fewer than there were
stuff so I'm another claimant when I
make is that F P style transactions is
are much more resistant to bloat so here
is an our interface that I sort of seen
what I call I repository and it's got an
insert methods and then later on they've
added an insert async methods as you
know and then later on the editor no one
a delete method and a delete async and
an update and update a sync and then
maybe I commit changes so they can
support something else and then commit
changes async because that's a new thing
they need support and then there's some
way of querying but then maybe you want
to clear by key and you query by filter
and then you query by some sort of
specification object and then you want
to Mai's it because the sequel is too
slow so you might have contains method
and then you want to optimize that too
so you have a count method and then you
want to realize that you're pulling too
much back from the data so you have a
summary record that you pull back
instead of all of it and then you need a
version two that's on record because you
need to be back compatible with the
previous one oh and by the way let's
change the customer password while we're
at it
oh and let's have a backward version of
that to version two of the passwords and
that's accidentally for admin purposes
for testing purposes let's have a
function called a method called delete
all those and the day baseball that's
great because that could never possibly
go wrong that would never be missed
accidentally you know only you only
supposed to use it in the test
environment just promise promise me
you'll never accidentally call it in the
production environment and then here's a
launch missiles because we really want
to cover every possible thing and of
course you need to backward-compatible
launch missiles version two so this is
the kind of thing obviously this is kind
of silly but I have seen interfaces with
like
thirty forty methods on it right so what
the problem is here is that you have
this interface that's trying to support
every possible workflow right it's
trying to support all the possible
things you could do with them with a
customer or whatever it is here you're
trying to yeah maybe want to insert it
maybe one delete it maybe want to change
the password maybe you want to launch
the missiles I don't know but you're
trying to support it all in one
interface and you know we have a hook
the whole principle in our design
interface segregation principle don't do
that you know don't make people depend
on things they don't use but it's even
even though we have this principle it
still happens anyway because it kind of
there's a kind of natural entropy where
we just things kind of get bigger and
bigger it's just easy to stick it in
another class trying to another
interface rather than making whole new
thing so you know I think Jeff Goldblum
had it here you know don't just do it
just because you can do it think about
whether you should do now
one of the nice things about the
functional thing is that you don't have
loads because a transaction square only
has what it needs to do its job it's
really hard to have plugs because why
would you even bother to write a method
that's not needed for this transaction
script you wouldn't your mother now if
another translation script needs another
method alright in that one but don't
write it in this one this one they tend
to be very very focused very very
isolated on these things they only need
what they need so you don't need to have
things like innovation interface
segregation principle and the agony and
all that stuff because it's kind of
there's a natural tendency you kind of
the pit of success you fall down into
not doing something well then having to
have in your mind it's to do it so
that's kind of nice so every part in a
transaction script tends to be relevant
you get that interface segregation
principle sort for free and if you do
want to remove something let's say you
see something is no longer relevant you
can remove it because it's these are
autonomous you if I remove from this
transaction script I guarantee I haven't
broken anything else all right we could
unlike if I remove a method from a class
who knows what people you're depending
on that method you know so you have to
do you have to follow all the users of
the method and it you know et cetera
cetera so right another claim we're
going to have which is that you can
modify these things with confidence now
again if you look at the COBOL code or
the Java code
kind of transaction scripts you often
have very worried about modifying things
but here is a version one of the
workflow and then I'm going to replace
that component with version 2 now I feel
confident about that for a couple of
reasons first of all when I place a
piece of the pipeline I haven't touched
the rest of the code I'm just replacing
that one piece so I'm a lot more
confident than trying to mess with a lot
of code I'm just missing one little
piece that's good and the other thing is
the inputs and outputs that I'm using a
statically typed language the compiler
will make sure that the inputs and
outputs still match so the example from
you know dealing with a deck or
something and I have a new version it
still needs to take a deck as input they
has to have the same inputs and the same
output so it's going to have very very
similar functionalities much less likely
to gonna get it wrong now if I want to
add features to workflow it's really
easy I just stick a new thing in the
pipeline and again I'm minimizing the
route code I have to write a I haven't I
don't have to touch any existing code I
just a new thing in the pipeline as long
as the inputs and outputs match up with
the types I have very high confidence
it's going to work if you need to do
branching again I can just do some sort
of conditional and branch on these two
things and if the branching gets really
really complicated I just have a
component again just like a dispatcher
or route or whatever that figures out
what's the input and immediately calls
one of these 20 other functions but the
individual functions stay very small and
isolated so the actual choice the
decision making is get separate from the
logic so it tends to be simpler to work
with and of course another come from is
you have two workflows and they're
almost exactly the same as if the one
tiny lil thing which is different so
rather than copying and pasting the
whole thing you just want to
parameterize it with that one little you
know parameter whatever it is and here
is an example you'd ever you have a a
workflow it's got a slot in it and its
parameterize and you pass in the thing
you need now that thing you pass in it
could be you know a constant the number
but it could also be a function it could
be the strategy pattern you fast an a
function to decide exactly how it
behaves
so again you have a very high confidence
that this is gonna work because the
types measure alright now what about
this which domain model that transaction
scripts don't have so here is our two
functions from our card game model and
if you see these things we're using a
word like deck and hand and player and
stuff we're not using instance strings
this is a rich domain model right now
the fact we've ever made them is
functions its it means that we get the
benefits of both the domain model is
used in these functions or these
transactions but the functions are
independent so I can swap things out and
swap things in without breaking
something else so all the nice things
about which domain model without having
things become tangled up where you can't
change stuff without worrying about them
and if you want to share a component
let's say I have you know I've built
this function that does a deal and it
has a deck as input over and I want to
reuse this component in multiple places
it's a very useful component well I can
just use it in all these places I don't
have to create an interface so I don't
have to retro engineer something every
function is automatically an interface
any function that takes in at X and
spits out a new deck or whatever will
fit in this slot so it's much it's
actually very easy to reuse things
without having to do like retro actively
refactor things and again I have a high
confidence that it all fit nicely so
shared components with which domain
logic is actually quite easy to do in
this approach so it is compatible people
say either you have a choose between
transaction scripts which is kind of
boring and a rich domain model which is
sophisticated and I'm saying that you
can actually get the best of both worlds
you can have a nice which domain model
which is super complicated with super
complicated business rules and still
assemble transactions in a linear way
which easy to understand which don't
have any extra craft in them still using
this nice switch to main one so the best
of both worlds
people who are you know when when the
whole layered architecture first came
around people realized pretty quickly
that there were some issues and the
onion architecture and they're clean
architecture and the hexagonal artists
reports and apps it's all these variants
of that started evolving and I'm going
to show you how this evolves naturally
from functions so here is a classic
layered model layered architecture with
an API layer and a services layer data
mainly on a database layer and some
workflow comes in to the API and it
comes all the way back out the API and
so on now we know one of the reasons
this is a bad approach is because if you
need to touch one of those workflows if
you need to add a field to the customer
you have to touch every single layer and
that really goes against the principle
you know code that changes together
should live together if you have to
change four different things in four
different places that's actually a
really bad way of organizing code so
much better way of organizing code is in
vertical slices rather than horizontal
slices and I think you see quite a few
people talking about this approach and
if you want to change one particular
workflow all you have to do is change
the bits that are relevant for that
workflow and you're not touching anybody
else's workflow so this is a much better
way of doing it
now if you take these things and you
kind of pull them out stretch them out
sideways you end up with something like
this so something comes in the API and
then it goes services domain hits the
database in the middle now just the
databases the center of the universe
here more domain stuff more services and
stuff so this is how you do it if you
stretch out on these workflows into that
on a pipeline and you can see it's kind
of ugly it's really confusing you're
doing things multiple times this is bad
so the answer this is onion architecture
or clean architecture or thoughts
adaptors whatever the idea is you have
pure code in the middle and you have all
the infrastructure or the API or the
database or whatever around the core and
that's it now what's interesting is this
is exactly what functional programming
is all about in frontal programming you
separate the pure code pure meaning
deterministic
the deterministic codes which is all the
business logic but no IO and anything to
do with interacting with the outside
world anything which is
non-deterministic is that the edges so
the functional programming and and the
kind of these kinds of architectures
really a match made in heaven I think
it's just a natural natural way of doing
things so there's a talk functional core
imperative shell which I'm sure some of
you've seen if you haven't checked it
out it's exactly the same things about
having a pure or core deterministic core
which is easier to test an iOS or the
edges all right what about testing these
things so I'm just going to review some
of the key testing concepts and I think
I stole this from Ian here because I
think this thing about the system under
- and you can probably correct me if I'm
wrong here so the system under the test
should be a unit of business value okay
so you should be testing business value
not just classes on their own so what is
the unit of business value in this idea
it's a transaction right that those are
things you should be testing don't test
the individual classes and you should
apply it you should test the boundaries
you should test you shouldn't be testing
in terms of things as those things
change and you're gonna have very
brittle tests so what is the thing that
goes to one boundary to another boundary
that transaction and then people think
unit tests mean units equal classes unit
is just a unit of functionality right
and it's a unit that a function and it
can be isolated and tested on its own
without breaking nothing else which
doesn't depend on anything else so
that's a unit of functionality not a
class equal unit so I think that's right
is that good yes Ian agrees so that is
the thing about testing so notice that
the transaction model of doing stuff
really matches this really nicely you
test transactions you don't trust
classes so here is what a FP style
transaction script looks like so you
have this big function but inside the
big function there's a couple of pieces
there's a bit of Io
there's your business logic and then you
have a row at the end so all the i/o is
at the edges you know in a fox
model so typical things you load some
data from a database you do some
business logic and you save it back to
database in 99 percent of transactions
are like this and if it's more
complicated you can make it more
complicated that's basically it really I
would say everything almost everything
is like this now what's interesting is
the business logic where you're making
decisions is deterministic
it's normally I have this piece of data
what should I do with it you know should
I accept the payment should a knife set
payment although all that all these
branches and the conditionals and all
that stuff that is deterministic code
and that is where the complexity is in
in typical most business logic it's like
it's complex but it is deterministic if
I have this input I guaranteed to have
this album now anything to do with
databases or files or the outside world
is not a terminus stick so it's really
hard to test that kind of stuff
but if you write your code in this way
with the i/o at the edges and the pure
deterministic business logic in the
middle it's super easy to test the
testing falls out without even thinking
about it because the pure determination
of business logic is a unit test is pure
you can just like parse all the inputs
in do your test and check the outputs
all right it's always going to be the
same output for the same input
completely deterministic now if you want
to test the whole thing from end to end
that's an integration test and that's
where you have to hit the database or
the file system or the network or
whatever that's fine but this comes from
this architecture the difference between
a unit test integration test light falls
out naturally and what you should be
testing you know falls out naturally he
only have to test the business not it
you don't have to test a bunch of little
classes and stuff if you do need to do
more complex IO you can do it in the
middle of the workflow but just keep
your eye out from your business logic
keep the deterministic stuff separate
from the non determinacy stuff right and
even do front-end stuff like you can do
front-end style like this too if you're
used to the Elm architecture or redux
the Model View update architecture where
you have this message pump and you have
an update thing and a render thing and
you have a browser thing these are all
functions the little update thing and
the render thing these are pure
deterministic functions which make them
really easy to test and all that IO
non-atomic stuff is in the browser or in
them in their library that does sister
so this is a reason why people like
doing this on the front end as well
alright let's just finish up with some
deployment options because what's nice
about this is you can actually get a
bunch of if you follow this approach
you're not tied down to running things
on a mainframe using COBOL you can
actually do some cool things so there's
three different architectures which are
sort of common use now so monoliths
right standard architecture so in a
monolith approach each of our bounded
context is going to become a module in
our module you know modular monolith and
because these bounded contexts are
autonomous and they have well-defined
boundaries and well-defined interfaces
we can still put them in a month but
they are modular so that's good now if
you have a service-oriented architecture
each of these banner contexts would
typically be in a container so a bunch
of Micra services or whatever in a
single container and if you're doing
service then each of these interval work
flows become deployment units right you
just deploy these individual workflows
because they're stateless remember they
have the i/o and the at the front and
the IP they're really easy to make into
lambdas whatever so server this works
really well for this approach so here's
the modular monolith so here's our here
are a couple of banded concepts three
pound of context and they have these
workflows but they're modular like
people say well I want to have you know
how do I get modularity I need to go to
Microsoft it's no you don't if you can't
build a modular monolith what makes you
think you can build modular
microservices but it's the same
principles is this a deployment thing
it's not about the design thing you
should always design things to be
modular no matter how didhow you're
deploying them so modular monoliths
there's the kind of boundary that little
red thing that's the boundary of the
deployment and you can also have a split
deployment where you have a front-end
part on a back-end part and they're
really part the same amount of context
but there's too little workflows and
they communicate with like an API so
that's what I'm doing it now if you're
doing micro services or container based
stuff you can each little contexts can
be its own unit of deployment I can have
docker container or whatever I know
kubernetes weather for service each of
each of these individual workflows
become something you deploy and what's
nice is that you can
if you if you architected your stuff
right if you design your stuff right you
can switch between these different
deployment approaches with minimal pain
I mean there's always gonna be pain but
you know as long as you design your
stuff to be modular notice that
everything here is completely modular
right so let's finish up we have the
reinvented transaction scripts so going
back to martin fowler's definition
business applications can be thought of
as a series of transactions we are going
to organize it as a single function with
a deterministic core and i/o at the
edges that's no longer a procedure which
mixes up database stuff and each
transaction will have its own autonomous
evolvable transaction script I think
transaction scripts should be more
popular so this is what the whole point
this talk is because there what's cool
about them is they are very business
focused when you do something it's just
about getting stuff done you're not
worried about which framework you should
use there are no frameworks in
transaction script stuff by the way it's
the whole libraries but not frameworks
it's very business focused actually
really good for agile if you're doing
agile properly because the transaction
becomes the unit of developments like
this like a story transaction the
stories like this is what I'm going to
do this week I'm gonna build this thing
and you focused on delivering business
value all the time and it's really easy
to understand because the data flow is
one directional right so no bloat or
less bloat of course you're always going
to have bloat because we're developers
but you hopefully have the force is
working towards bloat are countered by
the fact that these things are kind of
small and then all the problems that we
had we solve them with composability and
put in io separately so for example the
new improved transaction scripts they
have a rich domain unlike the original
ones they're easy to modify
unlike there is no ones they easy -
super easy to test unlike the original
ones and they're hipster friendly they
work with micro services and server
lists and all the latest cool kids stuff
so they're very cool the new improved
translation scripts definitely what the
cool kids should be using today so
thanks very much I'm going to post the
slides and videos my website there if
you like this kind of thing I have my
power of composition talk and my domain
modeling made functional talk I have a
whole book about domain modeling please
contact me on Twitter if you have any
questions and thank you very much
[Applause]